[Music]
I have seen a canyon go from a trickle
to 10 to 15 or even a wall of 20 ft of
water it's scary and it does happen all
the time in the deserts hey everybody
I'm Les stoud also known as Survivor Man
and for well over 35 years I've been
studying training and teaching survival
throughout the world today we're going
to take a look at Desert survival scenes
in the movies and in television and
judge just how real they
are showing the difference between the
sunny sky that you're in and the
sandstorm overtaking that as a big Dark
Cloud to me is very realistic it is
blocking out all of the light it's what
happens when we have Smog and smoke from
fires things get
dark they are getting them right I I you
know that the sandstorm happens
incredibly quickly think about when a
hurricane comes in or a tornado comes in
it's the same thing with sand you can
have the same wind speeds and this is a
wall of sand and it's coming at in at
you and it's coming in
fast Tom here puts on some glasses and
makeshift scarf that he steals as he's
running through the
market you do what you've got to do and
that is actually the key to survival
it's not about what's better or what's
best or what's not as good what is
working right now and for this character
he was lucky to have goggles and he
covered his face any way he
could your air intake on your vehicle is
going to be sucking up all that sand and
it's going to choke out your engine in
your vehicle so that I think is the the
harsher reality of trying to drive in
the middle of a sandstorm I'd rate this
clip a six out of 10 because the
depiction of the moving sand truthfully
captured what you might actually see
that is not the way that I would travel
through the desert on any given day just
traing up a sound Dune back down it
along The Ridges those Dunes can be
easily the size of apartment complexes
or city Towers they can be massive it is
difficult to walk in sand dunes it's
it's it's like walking in some kind of
weird snow you you it just every step
forward is a slide back and the trick in
traversing the sand dunes really is
looking for that path of leaf resistance
which is not always going all the way up
to the
top the beauty of most wilderness areas
whether it's the ocean or the middle of
a desert is that star expanse and it is
far more Illuminating than you'd ever
give it credit for you can literally
walk in the night through the desert and
see exactly where you're going without
any Moon just with the Starlight if you
can't do it at night and you need some
daylight fine early in the morning
that's going to be your best bet once
you get to midm morning and even late
day it's just too
hot the tripping and the stumbling when
it comes to all of our favorite Heroes
and actors as they try to walk on sand
dunes that's all Hollywood you don't
succumb that way and then if you do trip
in fall you don't just go rolling on
down a big Dune like that you you do
that if you want to you make a sport out
of it it's a recreational activity but
if you're succumbing that's not the way
it happens I'd rate this clip at three
out of a 10 three because it's just kind
of
silly I'm not really certain they got it
right at all and the reason for that is
quicksand primarily exists at riverbeds
estuaries close to the ocean that's
where you get your quicksand this
particular scene is set right in the
middle of the desert where everything is
completely bone dry and yet he just
drops into it kind of
magically
no that stuff is so thick you're not
just lifting your arm up saying oh let
me die just leave me here that's not
happening not when he was already up to
his neck and just barely sort of
breathing my first move in in falling
into quicksand is immediate and that is
this real simple Don't Panic that's the
first thing you do when you can't move
your body insane intense claustrophobia
because you can't move it's like you're
tied so you have
to breathe and not panic and then think
about okay how do I slowly and
cautiously get my body back from being
vertical to being horizontal and Slither
my way out of this and you end up using
like your fingers become like little
grappling hooks you just want to do this
it's literally an inch at a
time even to pull somebody else out
requires a lot of Leverage in this case
he had a horse so he had the leverage
falling into quick sand can be a very
slow death uh if you really can't pull
yourself out from all that suction it
doesn't mean you're also going straight
down instantly people have been stuck in
quicksand for minutes for hours and even
days it can take a while I'd give this
scene about a three out of a 10 it's the
wrong ecosystem his portrayal being
stuck in the sand was just a little too
over the
top the thing I love so much about this
movie and this particular scene is the
realism of his desperate attempt to get
a little bit of rainwater with his water
bottle he's holding it up trying to get
get these drops and that feeling I know
that feeling of dehydration where just a
bit of rain would give me some
[Music]
relief flashlighting in the desert is
not to be underestimated it's incredibly
dangerous it happens very quickly you're
rarely prepared for it and I have seen a
canyon go from a trickle to 10 to 15 or
even a wall of 20 feet of water
in a very short period of time and when
I say short period of time I don't mean
days I mean hours or minutes it's scary
and it does happen all the time in the
[Music]
deserts the way to prepare for flash
flooding is knowledge ahead of time
what's going on with the weather outside
of the area you in because the flash
flooding doesn't occur usually from the
rain that you're standing in in that
moment it happens miles away in some
kind of thunderstorm that's going on in
a mountain range it all gathers and
starts coming down through all these
creeks and cracks and crevices to be
right where you are and that's why it
ends up being a wall of water when it's
coming at you I'd rate this scene nine
out of a 10 the depiction of the rapid
flooding and his desperation in the
beginning of that to just try to get a
few little drops of water I thought was
spoton
I mean shouldn't we keep walking it's
cooler at night Mike in this scene is
trying to create a solar still in my
opinion he's doing it really badly the
concept of a solar still is that you
encase materials such as plants or even
you could have salt water from an ocean
and then you cover it over In the Heat
of the Sun and you have a cup there and
you have this taut material material
across the top with a weight in the
middle and then you get the con ation on
the underside of that tarp it trickles
along hits the center drips down into
the cup it's very very difficult it's
very timec consuming and the reality is
in this scene they do it just before
nightfall it doesn't work at night it's
something that has to happen during the
day in the Sun so that's why you know
they're not getting a pass on this
particular scene they did it
wrong I've done it exactly like the
scene that they show here I've done it
at The Edge Edge of the ocean uh on many
occasions and after 24 hours I maybe
have collected an ounce at Best in
perfect
conditions I'd go easy on
that when it comes to conserving water
in the desert the reality is you can't
and so if you only have a limited amount
the best thing you can do is actually
consume it and carry it in your bladder
rather than trying to ration little tiny
amounts of water rationing food is one
thing rationing water is something else
altogether if you have copious amounts
of water then great ration it out plan
it out you can last without food for
about 10 days but in the case of water
you're good for about 3 days after 3
days you can't
function so the urine question I know
that there are certain survivalists who
have said oh it works it works what the
way it works first of all is primarily
psychological so it's a matter of you're
putting liquid in your mouth but you
have to remember all of those toxins
that are coming out of your body are
coming out often through your urine so
you're you're toxifying your own self
when you when you ingest it secondly and
this is an important Point here when
films and many survival shows want to
portray drinking your own urine you look
at what they've collected and they're
peeing like a race horse when you're
dehydrated you dribble and it's tny
brown I got two of these you want one no
thanks gets cold fast this is the
Paradox of the desert that you can
freeze to death and that's going to be
at night so during the day it's insanely
hot and so the heat just dissipates very
quickly and it gets very very cold to
the point of frost on the ground I don't
want to underestimate the value of a
space blanket they do serve a purpose
they can
literally Save a Life they can be warm I
found the better way to use them is to
actually create them into a shelter and
if you create a shelter and use it that
way and then crawl in I found that
actually works better than trying to
wrap it around my body when they're all
crinkly and the type that you want to
have is the type that you can't tear the
ones I see Mike and Saul using you could
you could rip them open accidentally
just by stepping on them the wrong way
I'm going to give these survival Clips a
five out of 10 they showed a lot of
cruel things to do solar still they
brought up the concept of drinking your
own
[Music]
urine when you're in the expanse of any
Desert and all you want is a break from
the Sun then anything is a break it's
incredible the difference in temperature
from being under a few Slots of wood or
being out in the sun that is can be
massive finding a safe place to sleep in
the desert is really going to be a
matter of options you go with the best
option you can come up with if you can
make a grass mat and sleep on that you
do that if you can be on a rock
outcropping that is smooth and
comfortable as much as rocks can be
comfortable but it was heated during the
day then you do that the thing that you
don't really have to worry about so much
are the creepy crawlies to some extent
it doesn't mean that a scorpion might
not go up your pant leg when I'm
sleeping in the desert uh if I take my
boots off I hang them upside down or I
put them on a stick upside down so that
I don't have scorpions going up in them
if I have my pant legs and they're loose
I'll tuck them in with my socks so
nothing goes in my pant
[Music]
legs he was supposed to be asleep but he
was holding his hands in front of the
chest you don't do that while you're
sleeping there's bugs I must mean
there's
water when you start to see any kind of
life insect life Wildlife plant life it
usually indicates there's got to be
water somewhere that's where they all
survive themselves the insects the
creepy crawlies the flying birds the
walking mammals the other thing you look
for in the desert it's simply plant life
growth trees Greenery and generally
speaking the landscape is brown and gray
and dry but you see a little bit of
greenery over there that's the place to
go and check for water there we go
this is absolutely a place you could
find water I have found the cleanest
water to drink halfway up a mini
mountain in the middle of a Mexican
desert and I could plunge down into it
and drink it and it's safe sometimes
that's because it's a rain catch and
sometimes it's because it's bubbling up
as a spring from the ground the problem
with water is that people are quite
afraid of it to the point where they
won't drink and they'll become
dehydrated but the reality is that most
of the places we're going to be is going
to have water that in the worst case
scenario has jaria and jaria is a
waterborne parasite you aren't going to
feel it for seven days and then when you
do you take some pills and it's gone and
so that fear of is water safe to drink
unfortunately is is over pushed in the
face of dying from dehydration which is
much worse I'd rate this scene about an
eight out of
as far as the clothing you're going to
wear when you're in the desert the
opposite of what you might think is what
is the reality in fact more clothing is
better and the reason for that is
convection in a dry Desert Wind all of
the moisture is sucked out of your body
and it's actually your clothing that can
keep that in same thing for the head
sunburn you can be scorched pretty
quickly in the desert so covering your
head and covering your body is actually
a real good idea in the desert
I think that caves are so overplayed
when it comes to survival because most
of the time caves are dank they're damp
they're musty uh they're filled with
creepy crawlies the the floors are
Jagged and and Rocky there's no place to
sit let alone lie down so we often get
this beautiful Hollywood image of a cave
for surviving in those caves are few and
far between the wet ones that are not
appealing at all when it comes to
survival are much more common there are
a lot of caves in certain areas of the
desert that are quite nice to survive in
the thing that you have to worry about
sometimes in caves actually and
strangely is what you're breathing in
because there are an awful lot of
rodents that hang out in caves and those
rodents such as mice that might carry
hirus are pooping and when they poop
you're breathing in all that that dust
and that that manure that or bat guano
and that can knock you down really
quickly if you get a real bad lung
infection I'd rate this scene a three
it's pretty hard to to judge a scene
that is based on so much
fiction the way he catches the lizard in
this scene is a little unrealistic uh
the reality is lizards are quite fast
they don't amble about the proper way to
get a lizard is what with what we call a
switch where you have a long stick and
you sort of whack it like that and you
really want to dispatch the creature
before you go down and pick it up and
take it off and eat it there are a lot
of creatures that you can eat in the
desert but you do need to know which
ones are poisonous or not when it comes
to something like desert insects is it
brightly colored is it you know
advertising to you that hey I'm
poisonous look at all my fancy colors is
it moving along slowly along the sand
like it doesn't care about anybody why
is it doing that probably because it's
poisonous and most of the other
creatures know yeah don't eat that guy
that slow-moving millipede he's
poisonous these are methods of learning
about uh the insects or even the plants
for example and figuring out whether or
not something is poisonous or
edible join the hot Sumas we used to
suck on small stones like these made us
feel less thirsty if you pick up a stone
and you you suck on it it has a way of
stimulating saliva to be produced in
your mouth and that's what you want and
so it's not doing much of anything for
your actual physiological dehydration
but psychologically it's a great
help it's so cliche that in the desert
people always just fall face first most
of the time what we do is we we go I got
to sit down I got to sit down and then
we sit down I'm feeling woozy I'm
feeling wooy and then we faint uh but of
course Hollywood's got to make it happen
within four seconds so we fall face
first I'd rate this scene in eight out
of a
[Music]
10 ain't no use there
kid with every survival book you read
they show an image of somebody digging
down in the desert to get water I've
tried it so many times and I've never
found water yet you got to remember when
it comes to Desert survival you always
have to weigh the effort you put into
something against the something you're
going to get only water we're going to
get right over here ain't the best water
and it'll take time ah here we go the
Barrel Cactus trick once again we look
at a survival cliche when it comes to
the Barrel Cactus that you can get water
out of a Barrel Cactus yes or no the
answer is yes you can there's only one
species of Barrel Cactus that is
somewhat safe for humans to drink from
the fish hooked Barrel Cactus other
species of Barrel Cactus are somewhat
toxic and can cause diarrhea the reality
is that if you do it right away it's
it's awful it's it's a it's terrible
tasting but what this character gets
right is that it isn't going to taste
great and it's going to take a long time
that is the reality of a Barrel
Cactus people think you can just cut it
open start drinking that's not the way
it works it takes a long time to get
water out of a Barrel Cactus because the
water is not just readily available just
there in a pool it's water within the
fibers of the plant itself and I've done
it where I've squeezed used it into my
mouth drops at a time and even that does
not taste good but it can keep you alive
I'd rate this clip eight out of 10 I
would say my favorite desert survival
scene was Better Call Saul not because
they got it right what they did they
didn't get right but it was almost like
one of my own shows where they were
showing you examples of what you could
do and should do to survive they didn't
do it well but they were still showing
them hey if you like this video and
click on the next
one